あっー！
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
僕は
と呼ばれています
今まで数々のローションでの戦いを乗り越えて、
僕はローションを凄い上手くつかえるようになりました
僕はこの先多分、僕より がたい がよかったり、
凄い強力な相手と対戦することになるかもしれません
そういう時、どのように戦うのか？
そう、この俺ならローションを使えばどんなに強い敵も倒せる
今日はそれをちょっと実戦で見せてあげようと、思います
と、いうわけで今日はこのローションだらけのフィールドで、
僕より強い相手を倒してみせようと、思います
本日の相手はこちら！
プロレスラーの天山選手と小島選手で～す！　どうぞ
天山選手）ヴァー！
オㇻー
小島選手）ハイシャ～
天山選手）このヤロ来たな～
小島選手）はじめ
はじめ）かかってこ～い
天山選手）ケガするな～
全員）ハハハハハハッ
天山選手）俺が新日本プロレスの
小島選手）俺たち天山・小島、
はじめ）というわけで今日は、プロレスラー選手と、ローションのフィールドで闘っていこうとおもう
天山選手）やってやるぞオㇻー！
はじめ）シャー！
小島選手）オーラ―！
はじめ）あー濡れちゃったｗ
はじめ）そういうわけで、まずは誰だ俺の相手は
天山選手）俺だコㇻー
はじめ）と、いうわけで一回戦目は天山選手とだ～
ルールは簡単だ、転んだら負けだ～
天山選手）ｗｗｗｗ
小島選手）天山　対　はじめ
はっけよいのこったー
はじめ）たすけてー
天山選手）見たかオㇻー
天山選手）次はコジさんがおるで
はじめ）ヨッシャー　次は勝ぞ～
天山選手）用意はいいか？
はっけよいのこったー
小島選手）うゎーくすぐったい
はじめ）よっしゃー
小島選手）これヤバい一勝一敗だ、
天山選手）こうなったらテンコジでいくかー
はじめ）最後はテンコジ２対１で闘うか～
はっけよいのこったー
はじめ）うおマジか～
天山選手）挟んで
小島選手）ヤバいヤベヤベ
天山選手）ちょっと待って、わー
はじめ）苦闘の結果引き分けでーす
はじめ）ちょっとぬるぬるになちゃったんで、
ちょっと我々「シーブリーズ」で、ぬるぬるを落としにいきましょーう
ハッハッハッ、
天山選手）大丈夫か
はい、このボディーシャンプーと、リンスインシャンプーを使って、
体のぬるぬるを全部きれいさっぱり落としていこうと、思います
！！
ふぅ
すげーこれ
小島選手）ハハハ
天山選手）ちょ、背中も洗ったげますよ
いや～汗も出てしんみりしてスッキリしましたね
あ、どうもありがとうございます
天山選手）いやいや、本当にスッキリしたから、もういっちょ勝負しようか
小島選手）よっしゃもう１回やるか、
もう１回いこ
はじめ）いやー、ちょっとすみません・・・
ちょっとこれ以上は勘弁してく
うおおおぉ～